ok alors vidéo pas très réjouissantes
aujourd'hui c'est pas les bonnes
nouvelles je suis pas là pour vous
raconter des trucs hypra coule sur plein
de produits super nouveau donc
aujourd'hui je viens vous demander votre
aide parce que il ya des petits malins
des gros voleurs ou des gros arnaqueurs
ou une grosse bombe donc on peut le dire
comme ça excusez moi pour le terme qui
s'amusent à prendre des pubs à créer des
pubs en volant mon identité alors encore
bon c'est pas le pire vous voler mon
identité mais surtout dans le but de
vous arnaquer et ça c'est très grave
donc justement je les signaler à youtube
en signalant cette page c'est celle là
en fait vous voyez l'url ces anti
patrimoine un jeu les signaler c'est une
chaîne qui n'a strictement aucun contenu
qui reprends ma photo qui reprend mon
nom c'est une chaîne qui existe depuis
longtemps
s'ils ont raison le à propos google est
actif quand même depuis le 31 octobre
2010 donc je connais quand même 11 ans
que cette chaîne existe et elle utilise
cette 7e ou alors c'est tout simplement
des gens pour voler cette chute j'en
sais absolument rien pour promouvoir des
publicités des publicités mensongères
ils ont créé cette pub qui s'appelle les
amateurs de téléphones intelligents en
raffolent et ils vous font la promo de
l'iphone 12 pro à 2 euros
autant vous dire que c'est de la relaxe
pure et dure et je laisse il ya les b
youtube ne fait rien donc j'ai besoin de
vous j'ai besoin de vous pour dire s'il
ya les deux choses pour venir signalé en
tout premier set chaîne là il faut que
vous veniez ici dans à propos et vous
cliquez sur le petit drapeau en bas et
vous veniez signalé signaler la chaîne
la photo de profil signaler tout signal
il faut signaler en max pour que enfin
ils décident de se bouger un petit peu
chez youtube et ensuite il faut venir et
je vous met une fois de plus le lien de
la vidéo qui en ont répertorié en bas
pour vous cliquez ici sur les trois
petits points vous allez sur signalé et
là il faut signaler spam ou contenus
trompeur et il faut vraiment mettre que
c'est
escroquerie ou fraude et vous allez
dessus et vous avancez dans le
questionnaire et vous signalez ça parce
que c'est vraiment extrêmement grave et
si on regarde les publicités je vous
emmène sur twitter vous allez voir
garder dans mon dans mon twitter gardez
vous le voyez là hop matteoni l'ami vous
donc c'est une pub qui prend mon nom
annonce monsieur grenet faire donc
strictement impossible déjà 11 mai
devient pas mal quand même est sûr que
la pub c'est du non répertoriés et
youtube une fois de plus ne fait rien du
tout il ya la tronche
il ya mon logo des entrepôts ferment
leurs portes en europe 18 ans plus de 18
ans et pour uniquement 2 euros et bien
vous récupérerez dont il faut donc c'est
extrêmement grave extrêmement grave que
youtube ne se bougent pas plus la
nouille quand il s'agit de deux blocs et
des escroqueries qui viennent cibler
leurs utilisateurs une des gens qui
utilisent une chaîne en utilisant mon
image et qui surtout prennent de la
publicité donc font gagner de l'argent à
youtube en publicité est directement
sans rien faire donc il faut le signaler
et ça ça me met hors de moi et je suis
désolé je suis pas un garçon qui se met
en colère comme ça ça me met hors de moi
parce qu'on vient vous arnaquer en
utilisant mon image youtube gagne de
l'argent aucun google apps gagne de
l'argent au milieu et ils ne font
absolument rien alors ils vont peut-être
finir par le faire un jour ou l'autre
j'en sais rien lorsqu un modérateur
tombera dessus se dire ah ben tiens je
vais y aller ou je ne sais rien à ce
qu'ils ont submergé par des demandes
parce que ce genre d'arnaqué fleurissent
sur internet je ne sais pas toujours est
il que c'est là il faut le signaler donc
voilà je compte sur vous sur votre aide
si vous pouvez cliquer sur les liens que
je vous ai mis les deux liens vous
signaler la page vous signaler la vidéo
vous signalez larnack j'expliquais dire
qu'à une publicité qui tourne sur
youtube
en utilisant cette image que c'est de
l'escroquerie que c'est du vol
pour ma part je vais les poser une
plainte au commissariat
je sais pas si c'est dans quelques jours
en tout cas c'est pour l'histoire de
venir me protéger pour qu'on ne dise pas
il ya un monsieur gros c'est toi qui
arnaquent tout le monde
qu'est ce qui se passe et c'est arrivé
également à jb deuxième collection qui
d'ailleurs ma me l'a signalé merci j b
tu l'as vu avant moi donc voilà donc je
voulais vous le dire
et puis on se revoit dès demain pour des
idéaux beaucoup plus rafraîchissant trop
cool à demain